- [Interviewer] Okay, Raul.
- Yeah.
- Raul, where you from?
Where were you born?
- [Raul] Chihuahua, Mexico.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your family.
You had both parents growing up?
- [Raul] No, my mother is in Mexico
and my father is citizen here in U.S.A.,
but he died, let's say five years ago.
I meeted him three times.
I was raised with my mom only.
- [Interviewer] Oh, so your
dad wasn't really in your life?
- No, only three times in my life.
- [Interviewer] And
how was your childhood?
- How what?
- [Interviewer] How was your childhood?
- Ah, I'm the man in the family, you know?
I have to grow up fast
and start help my mom
with money by working.
So I'm start selling, I'm
like paperboy, you know?
Fourteen years, I start working.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- So I can help my mom with money
for school and my sisters.
So we can have some money.
- [Interviewer] And you
went to school in Mexico?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How did you learn English?
- Here. (chuckles)
- [Interviewer] You came here what age?
- I come here when I 24
years old to start working.
- [Interviewer] And how old are you now?
- I'm 42.
And I'm start learning with
a TV with a closed caption,
and with my friends.
So I wanna work here, so I
say, "I need to learn English."
And I never feel afraid to speak it,
so I say, "Yeah, if somebody
laughs me, I will learn!"
- [Interviewer] That's the key!
- Yeah, and my friends is show me,
like, "Eh, don't say this word,
you have to say it this way."
That's how I learn.
- [Interviewer] That's how you learn.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And at 24, you
did what when you came here?
You were working?
- Yeah.
I come in first, I have
a competition with,
I used to work with Motorola,
so they have the
competition here in U.S.A.
And I liked, when I have a chance,
they closed the fabric,
and they paid me my money,
so I just come back here and say,
"Oh, I'm going to try to find
some job here and stay here,"
and yeah, I stay here,
working construction,
tried to find anything, you know?
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
and you like it here?
- Yeah, I like it, yeah.
- [Interviewer] How does it
compare to your life in Mexico?
- Oh, here is better.
When I start working here, I can help my,
I have another brothers, so
I help them get his study.
One is engineer, another is nursing?
So I help -
- An engineer?
- Yeah, so I help my brothers
to pay his school over there.
- [Interviewer] They're in Mexico still.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And are
you a legal citizen?
- No.
- [Interviewer] You're not?
- No, I never can get nothing
because my dad never put that paper.
He never helped me to
get my status here legal.
- [Interviewer] And so
today you're living where?
You're on Skid Row?
- No, I just, I have a hotel room.
Yeah, the key program?
I'm staying there.
- [Interviewer] Okay, and are
drugs a part of your life?
- Not really, sometimes, yeah.
Because it's like,
I need to get off too
much problems in my -
All these problems,
sometimes I stress too much,
they press me, yeah, take
me down to use drugs,
trying to forget a little bit.
All the problems I have -
I open one, my company,
my painting business company four times.
And every time it's going down.
Everything, I lose everything.
- [Interviewer] And why is that?
- Because I always have to trust somebody.
And put all the money in the bank account
for IRAs, for pay insurance,
worker's comp, disability.
And they can take the money, you know?
And I no have access
because I no have a
social security number.
- Yeah, you're just -
- You know?
- [Interviewer] You're just winging it.
- Yeah, I only have that debit card,
I can take 300 bucks and that's it.
I can't sign a check, nothing.
They always have 100%
control of the money.
So every time is,
somebody's using the money,
they start steal the money because I make,
I can make 30,000 in one project,
20, 24, 12, 8000, 10,000.
They pay me big contracts, you know?
- [Interviewer] And
they're paying you cash?
- No, check.
- [Interviewer] And you
don't, do you pay taxes?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You do?
- Yeah, I have, the other way
I have to have the company,
legal company, with all the
insurance and pay taxes,
you know?
- [Interviewer] And
being an illegal alien,
how does that work?
- I have to use somebody.
He helped to put the company
and I have to trust all the money him,
he need to make
all the payments.
- Oh, that's when
you get burned.
- Yeah, and that is always burned me.
Because the people, they
no wanna do it right.
So they say, "No, I'm going to pay cash."
And they start using
cash, cash, cash, cash.
They block me.
I have to (sighs).
They left me with nothing.
I say, "Well, nothing I can do
no more."
- So what's the solution?
- I used to say, I say,
"I have enough, I don't want no problem,"
and I'm thinking, try to find
a way, but it's hard for me.
Because I don't have that social
security number, you know?
So I can put the company only in my name.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- I travel, I go to Florida,
to different states to paint.
Because I get a contract.
I work with really, really good companies.
- [Interviewer] So it's
great that you're working
and willing to work and
able to get good work, but -
- The problem, yeah -
- You got a problem.
- Is how can trust people.
I always trust,
but I always get lost
because that, the money.
- [Interviewer] Do you have children
or a wife or girlfriend?
- No, mm-mm, no.
When I have a girlfriend
is the same problem, so. (laughs)
I say, "No, no, no more mix."
- [Interviewer] That's
another conversation.
- Yeah, because it's the
same thing, you know?
One time I have a girlfriend,
she no work, nothing.
I give you 2500 each week.
On, man, she get all upset
because I spent 20 bucks one time.
Because I helped out my friend
to get a membership in the
gym and I paid 20 bucks.
Oh, she called me, like,
"Ey, why you spend 20 bucks?"
Come on!
- You'd been giving her
how much?
- Yeah!
- [Interviewer] How much did you give her?
- 2500 each week.
- [Interviewer] 2500 a week?
- Yeah, and she start
screaming for 20 bucks.
Oh, man, I said, "I no
want this." (chuckles)
This is a problem I don't
want no more in my life.
- [Interviewer] So you prefer, you still,
with these obstacles, with these problems,
you'd rather live here?
- Yeah, it's always, yeah,
so now I just move here and say,
"I need start settle down
and check what I can do."
I need to find somebody I
can trust, really trust.
- [Interviewer] No kidding.
- Because I -
- And if you were
to go back to Mexico, what would you do?
- I can work.
- [Interviewer] You can work?
- Yeah, I can find any, yeah.
The same thing I can do
here, I can do over there.
Over there I can, I know
how to work machines,
like CNC router, like tools.
- [Interviewer] And what
stops you from doing that?
- The pay over there,
it's not really good.
- [Interviewer] You make very little?
- I can make more money here,
and I wanna build my house over there
or make my things here, the
life here, I lose my truck.
I buy that, a Silverado, 2011.
I paid cash in one year,
11,000 in one year.
- [Interviewer] So now
you have no vehicle?
- Yeah, and I have to lose it
because that is a problem, you know?
When I lose money for other things,
I have to start selling my tools.
Because I need to pay
the people, my workers.
I can't leave with money my workers.
- [Interviewer] So you had
no problems with the law,
anything like that?
- No.
- [Interviewer] Nothing like that.
- Mm-mm.
- [Interviewer] You're
just trying to make a buck?
- Yeah.
And I always lose, all a lot of money,
all my machines, everything.
They are expensive machines,
and every time, every
time is the same thing.
- [Interviewer] As a man born in Mexico,
is everyone born in Mexico
trying to figure out a
way to come to the U.S.?
- Not really.
- [Interviewer] Not really?
- My first time I wanna come here
is because my dad, I wanna say,
"Help me to get a study
here, or let me get a job."
And he never helped me,
so I say, "Well, I will do it myself."
- [Interviewer] What was your dad's story?
Why was he not in your life?
- Oh, he just moved here,
he say, "I no have kids,"
and he forget about us.
He make money for himself.
He get married, he have another -
I have a half brother I never meet.
He never told me, I find out for myself.
- [Interviewer] I mean,
your solution might be
marrying a nice girl here in America.
- Yeah, but -
- [Interviewer] Who you can trust?
- I no wanna marry somebody
just to get the paper because
that's not me.
- No, no, no,
I'm not saying -
- People, they -
- I'm not saying
that kind of relationship.
- Yeah, people, they do
that, and I no like that.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, no, no, I -
- If I wanted to marry somebody I loved -
- [Interviewer] No, that's the only way.
- Yeah, yeah!
- That's the only way.
- Because people, they get twisted,
I no give me money, no, uh-uh,
I no want that kind of problems.
- [Interviewer] I'm not
suggesting anything other
than falling in love and
marrying somebody you trust.
- Because it's too many
problems, you do that.
And for me, that's out of the question.
I never going to get married somebody
just for the papers.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- That is something wrong for me.
- [Interviewer] Do people
do that quite often?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] They do?
- Yeah, I try to find
somebody, no, uh-huh, no no.
I don't want that kind
of problems in my life.
- [Interviewer] How did you
come to the United States?
How did you get here?
Is it difficult?
- No, I had a visa.
- [Interviewer] But
it's harder now, right?
- Yeah.
Love where I am, I just keep
working, trying to do it.
- [Interviewer] So if your brothers wanted
to come to the U.S.,
they couldn't do it now?
- Mm-mm, I don't think so, no, mm-mm.
I am only, all my family's over there.
I am only here.
- [Interviewer] And this
video, being put out there,
would it get you in trouble?
- Not at all, believe me.
- [Interviewer] Don't wanna get you in -
- I'm no afraid because, like I say,
I doing this because I wanna be somebody.
And you need to find a way.
Whatever you have to do it,
you need to try, you need to fight.
Always in the company,
they know about my status,
and just work, work, work.
My work is my recommendation.
So I never be afraid for that.
Any problem I get,
believe me, that's fine.
If they deport me, I know,
because I know the rules,
the laws, that is what it is.
So is no your fault, is no my fault,
I'm dealing, willing
to deal with everything
because that's just what it is.
- [Interviewer] You do
use drugs sometimes?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] What drugs will you use?
- I really use weed, I use
cocaine, I use crystal.
- [Interviewer] Mm-hm,
and use them a lot, or -
- Weed, I use a little bit, no more.
Cocaine, I use for one time,
I use a lot of cocaine,
but I just quit, I say,
"No, I no want it no more."
Crystal, yes, I smoke crystal.
Little bit, not too much too much.
The worst drugs is cocaine, yeah, that.
When I used cocaine, I used too much,
used for work, that give me -
- [Interviewer] Give you energy?
- Energy, yeah.
That's why I say, sometimes the pressure?
Because I have to work on
the day and night both.
- [Interviewer] So the drug use
comes from what, trying to -
- To keep working.
- [Interviewer] And deal with
the stress of everything?
- Yeah, for that.
Because I have to start one
job in the night, like 10:00.
And get off like 6:00.
And I start the next job
like 9:00 in the morning
and finish like 4:00 P.M.
- [Interviewer] Oh, well,
crystal meth comes in handy then.
- Yeah, so I because, sometimes
I have to leave some people
working at one job and they no show up,
so I finish my job at night
and I have to cover the day.
And it's hard.
I can find nothing that's keep
me awake and energy to do it.
That's why I say, it's not really good,
but sometimes is no another way.
You need to juice it.
- [Interviewer] But do you
think you're an addict?
You have -
- No, because I can quit it.
- [Interviewer] You quit sometimes?
- Yeah, I say, "I no want
it no more," no more.
- And you stop for
a long time?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] But when you need it
to work those kind of hours?
- I need to use it, yeah.
Because nothing is going to keep me awake
to work two terms.
- [Interviewer] So you use
it like coffee. (laughs)
- Let's put it that way, yeah.
It's funny, because I say,
"How if I used a lot of
cocaine, you get addict."
I say one day, "I don't want no more,"
no more, yeah, that's it.
I no have problems.
- [Interviewer] You don't
have the addictive -
- No, and this is funny for me.
I can say that.
Is the same thing, if more crystal,
I say, "I don't want any more."
I just quit.
I don't have symptoms like (groans).
- [Interviewer] Nothing.
- Nothing.
- [Interviewer] That's good.
Not that I ever commend drug use, but -
- No, no, yeah, but I keep the control
in the situation.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- And I know is going to sounds bad,
but sometimes you have to
use it to keep do something.
Don't let drugs control you
because if the drugs control you,
you're going to lose.
So always keep that in mind.
Don't let control by drugs.
That is my best counsel to everyone.
Don't lose that fight.
If you lose the fight,
you mess around with everything.
- [Interviewer] And how
are the people different
in Mexico or here in
the U.S. when you come?
Now that you're here, how
is it culturally different?
- Here, you have more
opportunities to grow up.
If you wanna fight for something,
like open your business,
you can do it, working hard.
- [Interviewer] And get job
training or an education?
- Yeah, yeah, you need to work hard
and you can get the money.
Little by little, you can make it.
Over there in Mexico, is
impossible. (chuckles)
If you don't have that cash,
you're never going to make it.
And here, you can open doors.
Work because you work, how you work,
how you do everything,
that is going to help you to
open that door for something,
for get that contract.
How you do your work is your
recommendation everywhere.
And that is the way I open doors.
I start working like
this, this, this, this.
Different companies.
- [Interviewer] You send
money back to your family?
- Yeah, always, my mom.
I take care of my mom.
My brothers, no more.
My mom.
- [Interviewer] And so what
do you plan for your future?
- I wanna make my life here.
- [Interviewer] You want to
find a nice, secure way to -
- Yeah.
- Save money?
- So I can open my company again.
I don't know when to stop.
I need somebody I can trust.
That person need to help me
like grow up really good.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, what's been
the most important lesson you've learned?
- It's hard but you need to trust.
Money is always corrupts people.
- [Interviewer] It corrupts people?
- Yeah, so you need to
keep, I need to keep trying,
but this is a big problem, you never know.
Money, when they see a lot
of money, thousands, cash,
it change people's minds.
So they can break you, they
can stab you in your back,
just for the money.
- [Interviewer] I like your perseverance.
- You know, but that is how it is.
So I need to find somebody the money's
no is going to break down.
- [Interviewer] Understood.
- That is the only solution I found,
but I need to keep trusting.
There's not another way I can do it.
- [Interviewer] You have a
good head on your shoulders
and you're willing to
work and that's important.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Okay,
Raul, thank you so much
for talking with me
and good luck finding somebody
that can handle your money
that you can trust.
That's important.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] All right,
thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.
(Raul chuckles)